Would you used to be considered the
safest country in South America and at
the same time,
the second poorest,
but now it seems like things have
changing.
You see,
Nicaragua is a country full of
contradictions.
It's President Daniel Ortega likes to
brag about his deep Marxist Leninist
reaps man's.
Yet he defines himself as a Catholic and
just even banned abortion in
country.
Nonetheless,
spine.
That facade of moral rectitude doesn't
man facing an open trial for abusing his
stepdaughter.
Displaying this Daniel Tiger's known as
a big time family man.
In fact,
you know the Nicaraguan vice president
is.
Well,
that would be as wife Rae Sarria Maria.
Yeah.
Right now you're thinking Ms Dot Ortega.
Probably not the kind of guy you want to
have as a president.
Rice.
Well,
before you start judging too harshly.
Here's the other side of that coin.
He's been in power since 2007 with a
popular support rating.
Higher than sixty cents and even we have
to admit,
but when it comes to foreign relations,
he's a genius.
Are You A.
is one of the few countries that has
ties with Iran,
Russia,
Venezuela.
At the same time,
the United States of America,
yes,
you heard that rise.
Many of his comrades in the Sandinista
Front,
his political party accused him of
selling his soul to capitalism and that
only entirely wrong here or there in
Nicaragua is a poor country.
It's also one of the most stable
economies in the region with an average
GDP growth rates of four point six
percent.
The population living below the poverty
line is getting smaller and smaller
year.
Yeah,
well,
just look at the immigration statistics
and you'll see an exodus of Guatemalans
and Mexicans moving to the USA.
The Nicaraguans citizens seem to be
comfortable staying in the home country.
Apparently that satisfied
fight with the political situation,
or at least they used to be.
The final straw came with pension
reform.
The government has reduced the amount of
money that tired people get,
and at the same time has increased what
workers have to pay into the system.
As you can imagine,
nobody liked this policy.
Now that the businessmen,
northern workers,
and this is how the biggest
demonstration against Daniel Ortega's
machine started,
they've tried to oppress these protests
with police brutality and massive and
prison.
Since many people have already lost
their lives,
even the government has said or owned
sympathizers to confront the protesters.
So far,
none of these messages have stopped the
demonstrations.
So now the question becomes,
why is all of this happening now when
Nicaragua has no economic crisis
whatsoever?
Are we witnessing the end of Daniel
Tiger's rule?
Oh,
we about to see the end of the
Sandinista,
Nicaragua.
Well,
today we aren't going to answer all of
these questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history on
Disney star.
Yeah,
I know.
The title of this section is going to
ring a bell for many of you.
If you were alive during the 90 days,
you might have heard of the Sandinista
album from the British punk bands.
The clash,
the truth is during the eighties,
Nicaragua,
it became a symbol of the struggle
against American imperial.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Exam,
the Sandinista friends,
it made its way to power off often
decades of a far right wing
dictatorship.
If I tell you that the Sandinista front
defines itself as a Marxist,
Leninist,
anti American political policy,
you won't be surprised,
but here's the funny boss.
They combine all of that ideology with
religion.
Have you ever heard of liberation
theology?
What it was in movement within the
Catholic Church,
especially among Latin American Roman
Catholics and his followers were die
hard supporters of the Sandinista
comrades there some message of genuine
Christian anymore than you see on the
screen now.
That is Daniel Ortega.
Back then,
he was already the leader of the
Sandinista fronts and the presidents of
Nicaragua,
as you can imagine,
in the middle of the Cold War America.
I wasn't about to let this country fall
under communist rule without a fight.
That's why then American president,
Ronald Reagan organized one of the most
controversial decisions in American
history.
For one,
he sold his weapons to the ISR elders in
Iran who were fighting Saddam Hussein's
Iraq.
Of course,
this was a top secret deal because Iran
was officially an enemy of the United
States.
After that,
he took all the money from the sales to
finance the so called Contrera in
Nicaragua.
The concert were a far right wing
terrorist group that fought against the
governments of Daniel Ortega.
I'm speaking of Nicaraguan,
a Soviet era on the American mainland
only two hours flying time from our own
borders or our own security.
The United States must deny the Soviet
Union a beachhead in North America.
As you can imagine,
when the story got leaks,
the media went pretty crazy and so did
the world of music.
That's why we have so many songs and
records from those times from the clash
to Kris Kristofferson.
Now,
you might be wondering,
what did Daniel Ortega do while he was
empowered?
Will?
In a way,
you could see that he set a precedent
for Nicolas Maduro,
Venezuela.
In short,
the Sandinista government nationalized
all of the companies that were in the
hands of the local oligarchs,
and how did they pay for all of that?
Well,
they did that by getting more and more
loans from the Soviet Union and of
course printing money like there was no
tomorrow,
and what was the outcome of all of this?
Well,
in the year 1986 soft,
a little more than five years under our
tag is rural Nicaragua with suffering
from one of the worst cases of
hyperinflation of all time,
the bitterest of the conflict
between the countries.
Former Sunday nice to leaders and
American backed rebels'.
All Nicaraguans shared one crucial piece
of common ground,
the reliance on the American dollar.
Just imagine that the value of the local
currency,
the Cordoba would value every 15 days.
This means that if you bought a beer one
day and paid,
say 10 goal date is yet to come back
four months later,
and the same beer would be over 3000.
Now we've told you many times here on
visual policy that the worst thing that
can happen to a country is
hyperinflation.
This is why despite the fact that Daniel
Ortega have so much support to citizens,
showed him that backs.
This is why in the year 1990 Nicaragua
had a new currency,
the Golden Cordoba,
at a different government this time of
conservative one during the nineties,
Daniel Ortega was the leader of the
opposition party.
Meanwhile,
the country was getting rid of that
hyperinflation and it was coming back to
the situation of stable pop.
No
Nicaraguans kept being poor,
but at least they didn't have big
surprises.
The purchasing power wouldn't diminish
because there's not so much inflation
and there were no more wars or terrorist
attacks
and this is how we get to the year 2006
the year.
When Nicaragua Hell's new elections and
not civil,
look at what happens
to Ortegas
in 2006,
so we'll take a [inaudible] to the
governments,
but this time he was a different version
of himself.
Of course,
he was still a member of the Sandinista
fronts,
but so many years as the opposition
helped reshape his ideas,
neil or take a no longer supports
Marxist Leninism and is now a supporter
of Ortega.
That is the problem.
Testimonial from a Sunday to supporter.
Of course,
this brand new version of Daniel Ortega
still sticks to the same old socialist
rhetoric is government guarantees,
universal access to healthcare and
education in facts,
but if the literacy rates and average
life expectancy have increased in the
country,
but that rush for nationalization has
given way to more moderate discourse,
look over there.
Look,
white collar workers,
blue collar workers,
farmers,
producers,
entrepreneurs,
small businessmen,
and big businessmen,
all the economic and social powers of
the country.
Let's work together.
Oh No.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Hand because does even more.
Thirty years ago,
Nicaragua was the guy that the US love
to hate,
but now they've signed a free trade with
America.
The so called Captain Mans,
they celebrate with counselor Naco
operations.
Bear in mind that the American
agriculture market is protected,
but chocolate coffee and bananas from
Nicaragua as the exception to that rule,
they find it way easier to get into
those American mark.
This still isn't the end of our story.
Do you remember about special economic
zones?
I've told you about them in a video
before basically that an area inside of
a developing country with lower taxes
and more business friendly rules.
Well,
Nicaragua has got one.
The images you're beginning to see on
the screen now,
they belong to an ad made by the
government to attract foreign investors.
If someone was thinking of investing in
it broadwell,
I would encourage her to come down and I
think they'll find the same advantages
that we found nod with close to the US,
a frog bilingual population availability
of,
of highly educated workforce.
Surprisingly,
it seems this insole.
Tiger came to power.
Nicaragua has been flooded with new call
centers from international companies.
She played a special taxes and most
importantly of all the opportunity to do
business in the only country with new
street violence or guerrillas
whatsoever.
So now you might be wondering what
happened to Daniel Ortega?
Did he have,
if any?
Well,
of course not.
He just learns that when it comes
through,
he does well under your rule.
It's easier to stay in power.
This is why in election after election
or Tavi gets more than 60 percent of the
vote.
Of course these elections are rigged,
but only a fool would say the total
Tayga has no popular support.
In fact,
there's also another reason for this
ideological change.
See if the economy of your country is
doing or rice and you control every
facet of your country,
your personal finances at giving to the
procedure.
Dawn,
great.
The precedent Daniel Ortega has put his
wife and sons and important government
positions while his family has gotten
rich.
Thanks for Venezuelan oil.
Meanwhile,
there's government has invested a good
share of that money in avoiding school
rivalries.
Eventually,
every media station in Nicaragua is
owned by the governments or some
businessmen that's connected to Daniel
Ortega,
and by the way,
there's a new social media law which
started to be discussed in March of
2018,
and this would allow the ruling class to
censor and chase political activists.
Nonetheless,
protests have started for a totally
different reason.
That's how I look at that.
Why do they protest?
In Nicaragua,
common wisdom says that revolutions
happen when it comes free.
Isn't a big crisis rice?
Well,
that's actually a big mistake.
In fact,
revolutions happened when a country was
going through dire straights,
but is now starting to go,
right?
Implying is this.
Well,
basically if nobody around you is
driving a cadillac,
then they're all cadillacs to be jealous
about.
You can probably see where I'm going
with this.
All of a sudden,
Nicaraguan saw witnessing the advent of
a brand's knew at least the friends of
Daniel Ortega.
Yes,
it is true.
The whole country is growing,
but some long growing faster than others
and only the most naive believed that
this new aristocracy got rich entirely
on their own merits.
This is what we call the populist
moment,
so window of opportunity where the
governments can change.
This is like filling a room with gas.
You just need flick of a lighter and
everything explodes.
Contract Marshall,
I n s,
s law has already passed.
In summary,
the government has decided to lower
pension swell,
increasing contributions.
Businessmen,
workers and students have taken to the
streets like that.
Spent years waiting for the opportunity.
Thousands of people protesting and the
government's.
The government doesn't know how to
react.
This is why they have forced all the
Nicaraguan TV stations to stop
broadcasting the demonstrations.
Despite all of this protests being
organized all over the country,
not only in the capital,
even in its smallest villages in facts,
we know about this because we've saved
thousands of messages from protestors.
As you probably know,
visual politics also got a Spanish
language version and those he watched
that channel from Nicaragua.
I've sent hundreds of videos from
universities in these videos.
You can see that students,
they've been sitting there for days,
people bringing them food and water,
but then a policeman will come and take
it away and we have plenty of images of
police brutality.
We're not going to show here,
but trust us when we say that the
Nicaraguan police,
they're doing everything they can to
repress these protests.
It's big time clash forces in what used
to be the most peaceful country in South
Korea.
Okay.
Now the question you might ask is,
is this the end of Daniel Ortega's role?
And as we always say here,
visual politic,
you can never make accurate predictions
when it comes to politics and economics.
Having almost a protest as doesn't
really mean anything.
In fact,
we still don't know if all these
political activists serve a common cause
or a common leader.
According to the messages we get some
liberal factions as well as some die
hard Sandinista people who feel the
trade by Mr Ortega's ideological shift.
As you can imagine,
things like special economic zones,
not very Marxist Leninist.
In other words,
so far,
there isn't much organization and
there's no real leader that can
capitalize on all this popular unrest
with.
Now this is hard to offer.
A real alternative to the official.
Yeah,
power.
That's our opinion.
Here are visual politic.
Now we'd like to know yours.
What do you think is going to happen?
Do you really think Daniel Ortega will
have to step down from power or will we
see many more years of Sandy aneurysm?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and please don't forget to
visit our friends from the reconsider
media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this video,
the one not mine,
and of course surrender that we
published brand new videos every Monday
and Thursdays,
so be sure to hit that subscribe button
so you won't miss any posts and as
always,
see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast.
See you there.